how much progress does a musician make
in 10 years well it's been 10 years
since I last recorded the famous piece
gymnopity number one by Eric Satie
and in this video I'm going to critique
that old performance tell you what I
would do differently today and then I'm
going to record it again for the first
time in 10 years and you can tell me
which version do you prefer that video
now has over 1.8 million views which is
amazing and this may come as a shock but
I hate this video I honestly really want
to take this video down uh I don't like
how I play in it I think my technique
and my sense of musicality and
interpretation has evolved over these 10
years I hope but I feel the way I was
playing back then doesn't represent how
I would play now and so it's cringy to
watch instead of taking it down though
I've decided that this could be a really
great opportunity using the last 10
years of my musical development I'm
going to now critique that video and
tell you what I would do differently
today by watching me critique my old
self you can see that a musician evolves
over the years and perhaps you can take
the things I'm going to say and use it
to improve your own playing so here we
go let's start the video and start
critiquing my former self
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the first thing I noticed is a look at
this video I didn't do too bad of a job
considering it was actually the very
first time I ever attempted to set up
lights and a camera and film myself
[Music]
so this is actually in my mom's basement
she had kind of like a photo studio set
up with with some lights and a camera so
I just decided to take one of the pieces
I was practicing and do this video
and at various points in this video you
can actually hear birds chirping in the
background that's my mom's pet birds
I'm about to really criticize myself
here but first I want to point out that
I do think what I'm doing here sounds
nice it's it's definitely pretty and
there's a lot of things especially for
what I was doing at the time that I
think are nice this was very early on in
my classical playing I was really a rock
musician at this time and I just cut my
hair and was just getting into classical
guitar so some of these things I'm doing
are pretty raw I think
foreign
the first thing I'm hearing is that the
tempo can be too fast at times I
sometimes rush and sort of distort this
beautiful slow ostinato and ostinato is
a repeating pattern throughout a song in
this case it's one two
one two three for me this pattern and
the chords he uses gives the impression
of kind of slowly floating through space
[Music]
it's very beautiful
that opening instantly puts you in sort
of a trance very meditative very
mysterious but I have the feeling on the
recording that I really didn't
understand this opening What I Hear 10
years ago is something like this
[Music]
oh
in other words I'm bringing out the top
notes G sharp G sharp
but that's boring the top note stays the
same the whole time and is not really
interesting instead it was really
interesting about this opening is the
part that changes what changes is the
bass a
a
for one the bass line but also and maybe
more importantly
it's the inner voices that change and I
think are the most beautiful part of the
ostinato
so we have a seashore
[Applause]
[Music]
and on top of that we have e
sure
[Laughter]
[Music]
and on top of all of that we have the
droning G
[Music]
El
[Laughter]
[Music]
so for me bringing out the inner voices
is actually the most beautiful thing at
least that's how I think now 10 years
later going deeper what I would do
actually is lean on the first chord and
relax on the second chord lean on the
first chord and relax on the second
chord almost like we're on a boat we
rock from right to left from right to
left and that's what creates that
beautiful ebb and flow
of the piece that makes you feel like
you're kind of watching the water
come in and out on the shore if you'd
like to learn gymnopity on guitar or
just improve your guitar playing in
general one of the best ways one of the
fastest ways is to get a one-on-one
weekly teacher and my wife and I have
made an online music school called
rpajato.com to make it easier for you to
find an expert teacher these are
colleagues and friends of mine who I
really trust and can take your playing
to the next level please check out
rpajata.com and while you're there check
out all of our master classes and
workshops there's over 40 hours of
material there that you can watch
that'll make you a better musician use
the code seti s-a-t-i-e at checkout to
get 25 off your first pack of lessons
back to the video another thing I didn't
realize and I actually remember this I
did not realize what key I was in the
notes are strange in this piece
what chord is that there's all these
accidentals four sharps I knew where to
put my fingers and I used my intuition
but I didn't really understand the
harmony I was playing and therefore I
think I missed quite a lot I wish I
could tell my former self the following
four sharps means we're in the key of E
major so the first chord which starts on
an a can't be the root position chord E
major the one chord the home base
instead what we have is actually the IV
chord A major e f sharp G sharp a the
four chord is based on a so a major goes
down to E major the one chord so in
other words the piece is a four chord
going to a one chord back to a four
chord going to a one chord the one chord
is the point of relaxation but so T is
too eccentric and one of them use it to
be two maybe impressionist to be so
simple so he makes each one of those
chords into a Major Seventh chord this
is a very Jazzy chord
very beautiful dream like chord instead
of the normal chord
[Music]
the beautiful major seven you could hear
it a lot in jazz and in Bossa Nova
that sound so 10 years ago I didn't
actually know that and I think it led me
just to kind of play
um nothing I just played simple
thinking that this is not interesting
and what's interesting is about to come
but the austinetto pattern by itself is
the foundation of the piece and I think
I really I missed that Nuance at the
time so now
[Music]
keep this opening a bit better and bring
out those beautiful inner voices let's
listen to some more foreign
[Music]
I think I'm doing a good job here at
actually separating the Melody from the
accompaniment so the melody is the sort
of the singing part that if there were
lyrics you could you could sing that
part and everything else is sort of the
the backup band right so In classical
guitar plan we often bring out the
melody more than the accompaniment and
I'm doing that here but what I notice is
that the second I start the Melody I
speed up
let's listen to that again
[Music]
to hear how suddenly it gets faster I
started one two three one two I set up
the meter one two three and the second
the melody starts it sounds like one two
three suddenly fast and for me this
destroys the beauty of that moment which
is the singer who is singing on top of
that beautiful foundation in the first
four measures so as you'll hear in my
new performance at the end of this video
I'm going to try to keep the pulse
steady
while
the melody enters
hopefully I'm doing it I think the
reason I'm speeding up here is very
natural it's because I'm trying to
crescendo
I was aiming here yeah
[Music]
and as a result I sped up so when you
Crescendo it's often easy to
speed up this is a trap you have to be
careful
[Music]
as we're listening I'm realizing another
thing I really failed to do 10 years ago
was I never actually looked up the
original version for piano real quick if
you don't know anything about Eric Satie
he was a Pianist in the 19th century and
he was a pretty eccentric dude he was
quite bizarre he wrote pieces that were
supposed to be repeated at 840 times he
only ate foods that were white in color
apparently he founded his own religion
and he encouraged his audience to
actually ignore his music and treat it
as background ambient music so gymnopity
is actually a set of three pieces that
he composed in the late 19th century for
piano the title gymnopity seems to refer
to something about ancient Greek dancing
some type of festival and all he really
writes is
which means slow and painful and he
writes two P's which means pianissimo
very soft
[Music]
originally for piano and being arranged
for the guitar it's so important
everybody look up the original version
all you have to do is Google the title
of the piece and then
imslp.org there you'll find many
versions of the piece for the original
instrument and arrangements and take a
look at the original version see what
markings the composer gives you it's so
much good information
I have to admit that for me the
cringiest part of watching this video is
how I move of course how one moves when
they play is up to us you know it's
preference and each person has their own
personality and style that's all fine
but the thing is I remembered at the
time I was new to classical music I was
watching classical performers and I saw
them doing this type of thing and I
think at the time it wasn't always
authentic I think 50 of what I'm doing
here is sort of acting and that's what I
really can't stand when I watch this to
be honest in the last 10 years a lot of
what I've been doing is figuring out
what is this thing that we're doing here
why are we playing this plucked
instrument you know and and making
sounds out of it as Shakespeare said so
beautifully isn't it strange that
sheep's guts should hail Souls out of
men's bodies sheep guts being the the
strings that were used historically
until the 1940s actually on guitars so
he's saying isn't it weird that we're
taking sheep intestines and putting it
on wood and then people are so moved
when they listen to it to the point of
crying isn't that strange yeah that's
weird and as someone who spends their
life trying to play as beautifully as
possible out of these instruments and
moving myself and others it's completely
natural to do some movement some things
require some movement to really play
well and I think we're kind of like
actors as performers we have to embody
the affect or the emotional content of
the song I firmly believe that and I try
now to only do movements and faces I
don't think about them nothing I'm doing
is because I think people want to see
this if I move now it's because it just
happens if I'm making a face it's just
what happens as a result of trying to be
emotional through my instrument
been 10 years ago I was doing that but
something else on top of it I think
there was some extra artificial movement
and swaying going on that's for me too
much at least now maybe in 10 years I'll
hate what I'm doing now one thing I did
kind of intuitively on this recording is
I kept that one two three pattern going
at the very end and I went one two three
one two three but in fact if you look at
the music it's really just one two three
one two three so I think today if I was
to do it again with that was
slowing down to end the piece I would
play one two three one
so here we go let's record the whole
thing and in the comments please tell me
which version did you prefer 10 years
ago or today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
as you just heard this is how I feel
about the piece at this very moment but
how am I going to feel about this same
piece in 10 more years perhaps I'll be
making fun of this version just as much
as I did the last one but that's okay
this is what it means to be an artist I
believe as we mature as we have life
experiences as we work on music our
technique our conception we use all of
that to interpret what's on the page to
be emotional to tell a story and of
course that changes over time in fact
maybe if I heard myself playing in 20
years right now maybe I wouldn't like it
but all that matters is at that point
it's the most beautiful thing to me
thank you for watching I have lots of
resources out there educational
resources if you want to learn how to
improve your guitar playing the first is
my online music school rpajato that's a
place where you can have one-on-one
lessons on Zoom with my expert teachers
these are colleagues friends of mine who
I think are fantastic and can help you
learn a plucked instrument then I have
online courses like classical tarpro.com
where you can do a self-paced course at
home this course takes you from a
knowing nothing all the way to playing
recitals lastly if you want extra guitar
tips and want to support my YouTube
channel the best way is to check out my
patreon like I said they get lots of
perks you can even have a lesson with me
and directly support the work that I do
thanks so much for watching don't forget
to leave a comment to tell me which
version was your favorite one and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
thank you